[Music]
let's rob a bank do what
now they cannot get
[Music]
away once upon a time I was just a wee
boy worked at the post
office don't ask you for 6 months to
chop that freaking yeti off your head
get it
gone
dad girl of my dreams marmalade you
going to show me right or
what from then on we was
[Music]
Inseparable my mom paid and raised the
price of her medicine overnight I say
when the system fails you create your
own damn
syst half a million dollars WR capoo we
got to take this
serious b b oh God D dear sweet Lord we
are
[Music]
scared it's time we start kicking back
get him the
CL baby I was just
playing I ain't no
criminal I've been chasing her for 2
years hey you see Mama's peels she's
just as much my mama know too
stop I can't tell if you're being
[Music]
honest it's me and you against ho W
world